little later okay come she ate it
ambassador Joseph Wilson is the author
of this new book the politics of truth
you have seen him talking on a lot of
the different shows over the past week
what's the experience been like well
it's up early in the morning and up late
at night and a lot of tea with honey in
it we're gonna open up our phones right
away because you have heard ambassador
Wilson over the past week since his book
came out I'm sure on other cable
networks and on other interviews so we
want to get you involved right away if
you support President Bush 202 585 three
eight eight zero if you support
Democrats 202 585 three at 81 and if you
support others 202 585 382 ambassador
when in the course of everything that
happened to you did you decide that this
book was going to happen that you wanted
to do the book well I had I had actually
done an oral history with the State
Department a number of years ago when
it's and as a consequence of that I had
been encouraged to write the story of a
career in the Foreign Service which is
why there's a good part of this it is
devoted to that in fact as I point out
in the back I wanted this to be
something that reflects well on a
profession that is poorly understood in
the United States well I think there
first of all we're caricature does
Pinstripe diplomats who hang out at tea
parties and sipping champagne and eating
crumpets when in fact the first line of
defense is diplomacy it is it is good
diplomacy that prevents our obvious and
need to put soldiers into action so I
wanted to get that out obviously when
the notoriety factor increased
considerably there was interest in doing
it now rather than later let me take a
sidebar to today's question because
Richard Cohen in today's Washington Post
talks about communication between the
Pentagon and the State Department as
it's a concern with Abu Ghraib in prison
and what's been going on there he says
this as is almost always the case the
Pentagon did not tell the State
Department that a we spot of trouble was
coming its way because as we know the
Pentagon doesn't tell the State
Department anything oh yeah I read that
in it's absolutely outrageous the
president's foreign policy advisor is a
secretary of state and unless we are in
a case of real war and then the line of
authority goes through the civilian
supervisor over there now you can make
the argument that we're still at war
with Iraq and that in fact those
military detention centers are part of
that war effort but there is absolutely
no excuse when the ICRC is making a
periodic inspections there for the State
Department not to be told about this
this whole thing has been an utter
disaster so does this mean that this all
should have come down through secretary
Powell well I certainly think secretary
Powell should have should have known
about it far sooner and the State
Department and indeed the US government
should have been reacting much more
quickly their reports out that not only
did was the u.s. aware of this as early
as January when they began the
investigation but did the ICRC had had
known about this for many months and
frankly I think those ICRC reports those
International Red Cross reports ought to
be made public we need we need to have a
full accounting of this the New York
Times has said to have a very
influential book review page and
yesterday they took on your book fairly
strongly a one of their one of the
reviewers Michiko Kakutani wrote and we
thought we'd give you the opportunity to
talk back to the New York Times this
morning through this program let me just
read you a little bit of what she said
and then you can respond she writes the
trouble with the politics of truth is
that it doesn't know what kind of book
it wants to be the lurches in tone and
subject matter make for a mishmash part
of the book is a coming-of-age memoir
with discursive accounts of mr. Wilson's
diplomatic postings in Niger Togo South
Africa Burundi and the Congo Republic
accounts that sometimes read like
outtakes from William Boyd's comic novel
a good man in Africa well you know life
is full of comedy tragedy and drama and
this wasn't intended to be something
that reflects a career in the Foreign
Service as well as involvement in a
political debate of enormous consequence
to the United States and then finally of
course ruthless government's decision
that in order to protect a political
agenda which is indefensible they
wouldn't go ahead and expose a national
security asset the book is what the book
is it doesn't pretend to be Ernest
Hemingway or Norman Mailer it pretends
to be
a history of life experiences and in
international relations as well as my
one of my objectives of course is to
enrich the political debate during an
election year the president has said
that he wants to run on his record and I
think that's totally appropriate I have
some rather trenchant comments I believe
on that record show picture of you at 16
what does this tell the reader well I
think what I grew up actually spending a
lot of time overseas I'd love I was
living in Franco's or Spain there as I
like to point out to people I've lived
in dictatorships from Franco Spain to
Saddam's Iraq and a number of African
dictatorships in between that experience
has made me ever more appreciative of
the value of American democracy and the
need for us all to be good stewards and
engage actively in the political process
I want to show this picture and maybe
you can tell me what year it is because
I don't see this was when Senator Shelby
and Senator Specter you and several
other people were meeting with Saddam
Hussein right what year was this was in
1988 I don't know if our camera if our
camera can get close enough but if you
can see this the Saddam Hussein is
holding hands with with Senator Shelby
who by the way he's turned 70 today I'm
sure that he loves this kind of his
birthday but first of all how does that
happen and then you also tell a fairly
humorous story about how people shook
hands with Saddam Hussein right well I I
found that to be a to be an amusing a
musing picture of Senator Shelby and
senator spectrum but I had spoken in the
book about about senatorial delegations
coming through and part of the process
of trying to engage Saddam in the
aftermath of the iran-iraq war in a more
positive way and Senator Shelby was
there of course if I were Senator Shelby
I would make the point that he was I was
a Democrat at the time that I was caught
holding hands with Saddam Hussein but in
the Arab world that is actually is
actually common holding that the holding
of hands issue as you're walking in the
touching and that's at that sort of
level and the shaking of the hands well
when I Saddam Hussein always tried to
create this this ambience in these
meetings that would be projected on to
his people
of superiority and one of the things
that you saw every night on television
was somebody bowing to him and the way
that he that he managed to get people to
bow to him was to hold his hand a little
bit low so that you had to look for his
hand in order to grab it and so that
naturally puts you in a position of
bowing and if you if you didn't look for
the hand you might grab some other piece
of his Anatomy which would have been
perhaps deadly ambassador Joseph Wilson
is our guest this is his brand-new book
that he's talking about it is published
by Carolyn graph just in bookstores
Washington DC first caller good morning
good morning ambassador Laughlin I'm a
former foreign service breath I knew you
well in the air as a child anyway my
question that I wanted to go and ask is
your take on the whole business of
having a certain number of civilian
counterparts in the in the Iraq conflict
I mean I guess the question I have is at
what point will outsourcing civilians on
very critical components of missions
that are generally reserved specifically
for specialists in the military or the
the the intelligence community at what
point will we decide to really think
about whether that's such a good idea
outsourcing that quickly first out of
the house well thank you very much for
your call and thanks for getting back in
touch with me I appreciate it I think
that's a that's a very good question
when we did the Bosnia deployment I was
political adviser to the commander in
chief US Armed Forces at that time in
Europe when we did it and one of the
things that we did is we made sure both
for force protection purposes and also
to ensure that the initial stage that
the reconstruction were handled properly
we the US military took responsibility
for that here in this case in Iraq that
was all outsourced and the problem with
outsourcing is you no longer have
control and you can't order the people
to do the job that needs to be done and
as a consequence you end up with one
because we were too lightly deployed out
there greater danger to our own forces
and to the
problem of relying on people who may
have different standards in terms of how
they assure for the safety of their own
employees
the net result has been we haven't been
able to manage the insurgency and we
haven't been able to manage a good part
of the public safety and the restoration
of basic services in a timely fashion
and if you can't get basic services up
and running then you cannot ever hope
that the population will side with you
against those who are fomenting the
trouble Sandiego good morning good
morning ambassador Wilson
I watched you recently on another show
that's in your book and one of the areas
that I found
greatly disturbing was that the fact
that your wife was exposed as an agent
what I didn't catch is how did she get
exposed who exposed her and what was the
purpose do you think that they did that
sure and in the book I try and bring all
that out because it's very clear to me
the people outside the Washington area
don't have a good idea of how this thing
is playing out probably because there's
not been enough reporting and one of the
reasons there hasn't been a lot of
reporting according to journalists I've
spoken to is there just simply concerned
that if they start reporting negative
stories on the administration they will
lose their access and they will lose
their sources and they will not be
confided and not be able to do their job
one reporter told me that he was afraid
he'd end up in Guantanamo if he broke
the story now Guantanamo I think is
metaphor for basically losing his job
and losing his access but it's pretty
clear from everything that I've heard on
some of which had been reported that
there was a meeting in March
shortly after I made it clear that I was
going to hold the government to account
for what it had said about this uranium
business there was a meeting in the
offices of the vice president at which
it was decided to do a quote workup on
me
now workup is run an intelligence
operation to find out everything you can
about this American citizen and his
family that explains how the day that
the day after two days after my opinion
piece would appeared in the New York
Times in July mr. Novak already had the
information on my wife it was leaked to
him according to a Washington
article was leaked to six reporters by
two senior administration officials two
days after or in within days after my
the appearance of my New York Times
opinion piece miss Kakutani
says in her article that you do not have
any solid evidence that you put in this
book to support those charges that you
deserve well I'm not in the sleuthing
business the purpose of that chapter was
to relate to a broader audience what has
been talked about broadly here much of
which has been reported in fact the day
that that the book went on the shelves
there was a report in the New York Daily
News a quoted sources within the Grand
Jury a close to the grand jury as saying
the grand jury was targeting two of the
people that I mentioned in my book
mr. Rove and mr. Libi it would be really
very easy to get to the bottom of this
and the fact that we haven't gotten to
the bottom of this in seven months
indicates that the White House is
stonewalling as I point out there are
not talking we're not talking about
hundreds of officials we're talking
about a few who have both a security
clearance that gives them as access to
the nation's most sensitive secrets and
a political agenda they're all clustered
around the around the office of the
president and the vice president the
president could simply ask them to to to
tell him the truth I'd start with mr.
Rove what do you know if you didn't do
it who did and the fact that they
haven't done it yet we haven't gotten to
closure is a clear indication of that
either the president isn't serious about
it when he says I want to get to the
bottom of this I believe he is serious
about it or he doesn't have control over
his senior staff and it's clear that he
has been far more loyal to his senior
staff on this and many other issues that
his senior staff has been loyal to him
or finally his senior staff is just
willfully insubordinate none of those
are satisfactory options page 397 you
say the press coverage was very positive
toward Valerie and me so was the
outpouring of support from across the
political spectrum from Pat Buchanan on
the right to Jesse Jackson on the left
did that surprise you no it didn't I
didn't this is as I point out this is a
great country we are Americans before we
are partisan the Republican outrage that
and
national security asset would be exposed
by a member of a Republican
administration was truly heartfelt and
much appreciated and I heard it from
really across the board there are just a
few who have tried to defend this or
have tried to shift the argument to say
well Wilson brought this upon himself or
I would just say one other thing about
that which is in calling on the
government to be truthful about this
business of uranium from Niger I was
engaged in what I consider to be civic
duty and civic responsibility this
country is is based on a social contract
and that that requires institutions the
Congress the United States in the
supreme court the Fourth Estate the
press which is protected in the in the
bill of rights and indeed individual
citizens to call their government to
account and have the government we're
responsible to the citizenry of this
country friends with main hello you're
next good morning
yes good morning all right Thank You
c-span ambassador Wilson I saw you on
The Daily Show it was really great to
see you and I think you have a wonderful
sense of humor and which must be taking
you through all of this I'm really
surprised that Robert Novak is still
working for CNN it seems to me that he
he is not a good reporter he's so biased
do you really think you mentioned on the
daily show do you really think that
we're going to get to the bottom of this
in this administration
thanks and I'll take my answer rocky oh
yeah well thank you very much I'm
auditioning my ambition for a next
career is to be a straight man to Jon
Stewart who was one of the most
wonderful purveyors of American politics
to the country that I know and I love
the joy I love the show
with respect to Novak you know obviously
CNN has to make that decision I've
certainly was spoke to senior officials
on CNN literally within hours of
becoming aware that mr. Novak was
gossiping in this being in the streets
of Washington to absolute strangers and
and giving my wife's name to people that
that he had never met before even before
he wrote his article and he
before he had the confirmation that he
felt he needed to go to print with the
article now I find that ethically
challenged to say the least and and and
really unforgivable but it's a decision
that CNN obviously needs to make and I
forgot the second part of the question
it's early in the morning maybe that was
it thank you
there are several pictures of your
children mm-hmm and the photos that you
include here which we can show this is
one with Tom Foley on the floor of the
house that's my first set of twins your
first they're now adults these are
adults yes sir you have another set of
you indeed I have a set of four year old
twins that's a lot of twins that's four
in total why you have pictures of them
and these the other children I know
that's the same the same kids I'll go a
little bit older why no why no picture
of your wife in the photos here well
once she was exposed it became clear
that she was under some potential
security threat no those threats come
from three sources one a hostile
television service which is highly
unlikely because they don't engage in
that sort of business to would be an
international terrorist organization
which against that threat we would have
to devise other security measures and
three would be just the individual on
the street who seems to believe that the
CIA is responsible for all the ills that
he feels so we decided consciously that
that was the one threat that we needed
to perhaps take some measures to to
lessen and one of those measures is to
ensure that she is not easily
recognizable on the sidewalks of
Washington people who are public figures
know what it's like to be to have some
bit a stranger walk up to you in a
restaurant or on a sidewalk and talk to
you or accost you in one way or another
she does not need that several pictures
of ambassador Wilson with President
Clinton from his book as we take our
next call from Winter Haven Florida
hello Winter Haven please go ahead hear
me no okay now thank you okay the
question I had for the ambassador is
when you went to work for the CIA to go
to Niger did you sign a secrecy
agreement and if you did
when you published your opinion did you
violate that secrecy agreement and if
you did should you be indicted for it
well that's a good question in fact I
did not go to work for the CIA they
asked me to undertake this trip which I
agreed to take not on behalf of the CIA
but on behalf of the US government I
made it clear before I left that I would
brief the State Department and secure
the permission of the ambassador before
I went out there I also went out pro
bono I offered my time to my government
because this was a my judgment a very
serious allegation if in fact we had
found that Saddam was attempting to
purchase uranium that would have been
prima facie evidence that he was
attempting to reconstitute his nuclear
weapons program and I like to remind
people by the way that nuclear weapons
kill Americans they don't kill just
Republicans or Democrats and when you
talk about national security you're
talking about the security of all
Americans I didn't sign any secrecy
agreement and if you go back and you
take a look at the article itself it's
entitled what I did not find in Africa
so it is really difficult to think that
any confidential information might have
been disclosed when there was no
confidential confidential information
found in fact we'd go to Ohio next to
Grove City Ohio good morning good
morning ambassador Breslin just got a
couple short questions I want to get
back to the Robert Novak of exposure
basically you know I've worked in a
prison system for 18 years in the state
of Ohio and my understanding is that
there are laws that involved exposure of
CIA agents Mike my take on it is I
really think that Robert Novak is
engaged in criminal activity I really
believe that his actions are actually
treasonous by exposing your wife have
you consulted any attorneys over this
issue and I know there's freedom of
speech issues in this country and Robert
Novak has a right to print anything he
wants to but he has a responsibility in
terms of what he prints also you know he
can't go around exposing national
secrets and stuff and then just walk
away from it and I'm just kind of
curious how you're taking off how to
hang on it I'd like to hear your reasons
okay thanks color thanks very much
I
there are a number of laws that people
are looking at in terms of this one is
in intelligence identities Protection
Act another one is perhaps even the
Patriot Act which might convey but what
I always like to say about mr. Novak is
whatever I may feel about him personally
as a former officer this government who
swore to uphold and defend the
Constitution United States I would
defend his right to publish to the death
what I do say about him I have two
questions one is if you read his article
the inclusion of my wife's name and her
occupation adds nothing to advance the
story it is just gratuitous therefore
you ask yourself if he was X if he was
exercising his craft responsibly and -
he says that he sought a confirmation
from the CIA and they gave him a quote
soft no as opposed to hard no so my
other question for him is what part of
no didn't you understand now my real
problem with Novak occurs before he
writes the article when he's walking
down the streets of Washington and a
stranger starts speaking to him and he
discloses to the stranger a man he's
never met before that the name of my
wife and her identity I wonder if he
talks to a stranger who happens to know
me what are the odds of that and my
question really is how many other
strangers did he did he share this
information with before he got the
confirmation I think the whole thing has
been very recklessly handled by him now
with respect to treason the the act of
betrayal of the country or the act of
becoming an insidious traitor as the
former George Bush called people who
leaked the names of assets to to the
public at large occurred when two senior
White House officials called six
journalists those are the ones who in
the words of former Bush former
President Bush who are the insidious
traitors and if I tell you as one who
went to the first Gulf War under the
command of the first President Bush when
he says that that is good enough for me
and that's a picture of you and the
first press first George Bush in your
book along with a note of which Oh a
note that he sent to you that's correct
next is a Spokane Washington good
morning yes ma'am
good morning Connie I can't believe that
previous caller stole my thunder I I
hope you bear with me here I'll cut this
a little shorter than it would have been
otherwise there's only a second time
I've ever been able to get through I'm a
little nervous but the other time I
called and got through mr. ambassador I
talked to you last year when you were
first on as you know Spokane's just up
the road from a small town called Cheney
I think it was named after one of your
favorite people oh not at any rate I
really admire your record of service
especially when I think about you
actually took the mission to this year
without a salary I says that's something
about something about your character
also I wish you luck because I I know
what people can do in a position of
power and I hope you and your wife keep
giving each other strength but on this
business of novak and journalists i hope
that you and people in a position of
power can rethink this a little bit
because actually the the person that
wanted to do the damage couldn't have
done it without mr. Novack he really is
actually an accomplice to this thing and
so what we're doing by these statutory
laws protecting these people is we're
almost encouraging to continue to do
this sort of thing so mr. Novack and his
alleged source can keep doing this over
and over again and endangering people's
lives and if in fact and I'm almost done
now if in fact mr. Novack were to go to
the FBI give them the name of this
individual who endangered people's lives
on national security think of the
message that it would send to other
potential sources the message is this if
you involve me a journalist in something
that's illegal
you have virtually waived your right to
anonymity and I really truly hope that
somebody can fix our jurisprudence
system and I admire you sir and I really
hope you revisit though your thinking on
this issue thank you well thank you so
much and I'd like to revisit Spokane I
actually went to graduate school in
Cheney and loved it and thank you so
much for calling back brings back fun
Marie's both of last year and of end of
Eastern Washington the fact that that I
try and be as as consistent with my
interpretation of the Constitution
doesn't mean that I think that Novak is
a good guy in fact the term used by John
Stewart the other night calling of a
douchebag is about what I would I think
about him but the real treasonous
activity occurs when that leak occurs
now I agree with you that it is
important to get at who did that and I
agree with the with with what you had to
say that the fact of the matter is that
that leaker is still in a position where
he has access to the secrets of the
United States and he obviously still has
a political agenda
now the fact is that Novak may not be
out of the woods on this there is in the
sort of interpretation of how you
protect your sources it's been decided
that you can force the journalists to
disclose sources I went to the Supreme
Court but I also agree with you and I've
heard this from other journalists that
if a source provides you with
information that is essentially untrue
or the for the purposes of providing
well for the purposes of just of putting
a lie out in there into the into the
public realm then you do not have an
obligation to protect that source
I don't think Novak would buy into that
in fact I think Novak would rather look
forward to going to jail and trying to
cast himself as a martyr protecting
sources he is no martyr he is a well he
is what Jon Stewart says he is came to
the Foreign Service in 76 that's correct
left in 98 and why did why did you leave
in 98 I left in 98 because I had really
accomplished everything I wanted to do I
was newly married and we were going to
start a family and the time had come
really to to go and do something else I
had been an ambassador of fact I was
appointed I was one of the youngest
ambassadors and the in the Foreign
Service when I was appointed he would
give all I went to Gabon into Southam
and príncipe which is an island
archipelago off the coast I had served
as the president's special assistant and
Senior Director for African affairs and
Clinton administration and had the
enormous privilege of taking the
president to a continent where I had
served a good part of my career Africa
for 11 days and that seemed to me to be
the perfect time to move on and do
something else
picture in your book with you with the
president of Gabon at the time what year
was it let me see that with that would
have been 1992 92 and if you come down
to see another picture of you at Jesse
Jackson and Leon Sullivan in Gabon and
that's right wanted one of their visits
to the country that's right the the late
Leon Sullivan had a biannual summit in
Africa called the African African
American summit and it was hosted in
Gabon while I was there he was a
spellbinding orator and a man who did
spent his entire life bringing African
Americans and Americans together he was
a really a wonderful wonderful person
Portland Oregon your next good morning
Iran with the ambassador good morning
ambassador speaking of insidious traders
do you believe that there's an imminent
danger that the Bush administration and
his cronies are heading us towards a
real serious dictatorship we are a
strong strong democracy and we have
institutional safeguards that prevent
prevent us moving into a dictatorship I
will say that I think this is the most
anti-democratic and democratic and the
small D of any administration I've ever
seen the idea of calling editors when
you disagree with even a mildly critical
article and these telephone calls occur
at a very high level I have one
journalist who told me that he had
written an article about the White House
about the vice president mr. Libby and
mr. was mildly critical mr. Libby called
his editor and ranted at him for for a
considerable period of time I have
friends who are very senior in the
journalists business who talk about even
the most mildest criticism being reacted
to by the administration I think that's
an infringement on on the Free Press I
note yesterday in The New York Times
that Disney is not going to permit a
Miramax to distribute the new film by
mr. Mohr and one of the allegations in
that article is that they fear that it
will affect their tax credits I was with
a sin
last night who said to me that the
Republicans are going around to
suppliers people that they buy things
from and going through their list of
corporate officers to determine whether
those officers have contributed to
Democrats before and in selecting their
vendors based upon the private donations
that officers as individuals have made
to enrich the political debate in this
country I find that absolutely
outrageous our state Department
officials allowed to contribute to
political campaigns yes indeed they are
they we are as career officers in the
federal government you're covered by
what is known as the Hatch Act the Hatch
Act circumscribes your political
activities so you cannot host a
political fundraiser for example but as
an American citizen you have the same
rights as other citizens to participate
in the political process both by voting
and by contributing to the candidate of
your choice Key Largo Florida hello good
morning investors
thank you for your service to our
country in your book you you go a lot
after liberal Libby is named Scooter
Libby that's correct and at the
beginning of this fiasco you went a lot
after Karl Rove practically accusing
both of them of doing the crime do you
have any evidence towards that and I
have another question what's the second
question when when when you investigated
in Nigeria and the president came up
with the the 16 words and there's speech
there the State of the Union he he was
not lying because Nigeria is just one
country in in Africa thank you I sure
with respect your first question what I
did in my book is I shared with a
broader audience what I've heard from a
number of journalists for many months I
have sat at the at the information
exchange on this particular issue and
people have come to me and shared with
me everything that they have heard as
well as as what they're hearing out of
the grand jury as to the testimony being
being offered again I go back to what I
what was published in the in the new
newse the day that my book went on they
went on the shelves the effect that that
libyan rove are target's of the grand
jury investigation now when I spoke
about Rove and I'm I spoke about Rove
out in Seattle when I suggested he ought
to be frog-marched out of the White
House in handcuffs it was really because
mr. Rove is ahead of the political
office and the political office is
responsible for for this was a political
attack that was that was run against my
wife and myself so it seemed to me that
the first place to go would be mr. Rove
now everybody that I have spoken to
about this who knows something about it
directly or indirectly says that in fact
it was a conspiracy that there was a
meeting and at that meeting it was
decided to do an intelligence operation
against me and at that meeting and there
was connectivity there was contact
between mr. Libby and mr. Rove mr. Rove
may not have made those phone calls but
mr. Rove certainly pushed the story for
a week afterwards including calling mr.
Matthews Chris Matthews a host of CNBC
or MSNBC s a hardball and saying to him
that Wilson's wife is fair game now I
find that if it's not illegal it is
certainly unamerican now with respect to
any share in the country is Nichiren i
ger and not nigeria you're absolutely
right the president caveated his
statement the State of the Union address
by referring to British intelligence and
talking only about uranium coming from
Africa it was in March that it became
clear by the publication of these
documents at the head of the
International Atomic Energy Agency
declared were not authentic and the
State Department acknowledged that the
country to which the president was
referring was new share so it's hard to
get out from under that the fact that he
chair was the country to which the
president was referring in the State of
the Union address and you can say that
he was technically actor in fact mr.
Rumsfeld has said that in a number of
interviews but it certainly is clear
after all this evidence has come out
evidence that the Vice President had
asked the CIA briefer even before I went
to Nisha and had gotten a response from
the briefer that there was nothing to
this he said that in an interview with
mr. Russert Russert
there were two memos and a phone call
during the summer and the fall of 2000
and and two from CIA to retro tenets to
the national security adviser and her
deputy the statement was pulled out of
the Cincinnati speech all that tells you
that the claim was weak and should never
have been the State of the Union address
now the question really is why did it
get in the State of the Union address
was it as dr. rice suggests a lapse of
memory or was it a deliberate attempt to
deceive the Congress the United States
and the American people about why we
were going to war that manner
this is a question I want to ask this
feller
I voted I'm gonna vote for President
Bush and I think he's doing everything
he can to get rid of it
and I'm you know what I think I think he
told on his wife itself to push his
agenda his book and get ahead and I
think he wanted to own his wife mr.
Wilson well thank you very much for your
comments I hope you'll take the time to
read the book Plainsboro New Jersey hi
mr. ambassador good morning morning like
to thank you I think he deserves a lot
of credit in admiration for what you
have done the principle involved here I
actually had two questions there's a
question is you had mentioned that there
was a number of other journalists
contacted and I've tried to keep up on
this and I've seen you on a number of
shows is there any reason I haven't seen
any of them come forward not to say who
the source was but just to come out too
in a way
back up what you're saying and the
reasons behind that or anything like
that no you're absolutely right and and
they have not come forward I know of a
couple of them again what I have heard
is that they are concerned about coming
forward less their access to the White
House is cut off that is basically the
way the White House lays this out if you
if you do something that we don't like
we will not share with you any
information
in the future and information is the
lifeblood of American journalism my own
sense of this is that the the the press
is a brigade is is just simply not
living up to its responsibilities to
hold the government to account there
have been fundamentally the the press
has forgotten that it always has the
last word and the administration needs
the press at least as much as the press
needs the administration with respect to
your credit and admiration comment thank
you very much I would just go back and
say what I've said repeatedly on this
this is not a matter of courage or
heroism or or anything other than simple
civic duty this is what we do as
Americans so government serves the
people of the United States we the
people of the United States have an
obligation as stewards of our democracy
to hold our government to account book
reviewer for the New York Times Michiko
Kakutani says that part of this book is
a reasoned analysis of the intelligence
missteps behind the war against Iraq
coupled with some prescient meditations
on the difficulties of regime change in
democratization what have you seen in
your careers to stay in in the State
Department that gave you some some
thoughts about how we're handling Iraq
now well of course having served in Iraq
for two-and-a-half years gave me a
certain amount of experience in that and
I put in the back of my of the book the
articles that I wrote during and in the
run-up to the debate I always believed
that that we had to operate on the on
the assumption that Saddam had weapons
of mass destruction and that there had
been a lapse in our coverage of that
problem and containment of that problem
from the time that we did a military
operation in 1998 called Desert Fox
until such time as the president went up
to the UN and was able to get UN
Security Council resolution 1441 passed
unanimously I thought and still believe
that the appropriate response was to be
really very tough diplomatically get
that UN resuscitate the International
will to go in and ensure that he was not
reconstituting his weapons of mass
destruction problem and that included in
order to get his attention having at
your disposal the credible threat of
force
if needed where I differed with the
administration was one the objectives
for the use of that force and two
obviously the need to use it and I read
and I point out in there when I read and
saw : Powell's speech the United Nations
it was clear to me that that resolution
was in fact working and if you go back
and you read the speech rather than look
at the theatrical presentation a lot of
people will come to that same conclusion
in fact at the time of the speech I
called some people who were involved in
disarmament activities and they said
disruption is a key measure of success
of disarmament programs and what :
Powell just said up here is that we are
successfully disrupting his programs
that obviates the need to invade conquer
and occupy Baghdad I worried that
virtually everything we see coming true
would be the result of an occupation I
said that in February of before the war
on an interview with mr. Moyers and I
wrote about it again in September after
the war people who have read all of this
have said you were prescient it wasn't a
question of being prescient it was a
question of having had some experience
on the ground this war was managed by
people from think tanks in Washington
and posh clubs in London without little
understanding of the dynamics in the
region and in Iraq this picture taken in
August of 1990 became a fairly famous
photograph at that time because you were
sitting there instead of the ambassador
it was April Glaspie she was out of the
country she was out of the country uh of
our viewers over the years have been
very critical many times of April
Glaspie for how she handled Saddam
Hussein at that time you knew her you
know her what right what how did you
feel about it at the time and what's
your take on what happened then I try
and bring some perspective to that
meeting that she had had with Saddam
Hussein a week before in the book
because I think history so far has has
has not judged her accurately and her
performance of that meeting accurately
when she went into the meeting with
Saddam Hussein on the 26th of July she
repeated to him what American policy has
been towards these border disputes that
you have in the region
ever since they started having these
border disputes which is when they set
up these countries and that position has
always been that we our strong view is
that this that you should resolve them
diplomatically and through through
international mediation we don't take
positions on the merits of either side's
case it's as simple as that now just
before he passed away I had lunch with
Nizar hemmed in who had been at that
meeting he was the Undersecretary of
foreign for foreign affairs had been
ambassador in United States was
subsequently ambassador United Nations
and I asked him about the meeting and he
said that in fact Saddam Hussein did not
see and did not feel that he had gotten
anything other than the the US policy on
on this at the time that he had the
meeting that the meeting had not
influenced his behavior what he did say
was that he was surprised at a letter
that came a couple of days later from
President Bush seemed to be so mild in
tone and that I put that in there
because I think that's probably a lesson
for the future it's not intended to be a
criticism of the first President Bush
because that letter I think was drafted
probably at the State Department but it
was just to just sort of round off the
history of this a little bit where is
April Class B today she's retired and I
think she's I don't know exactly where
she is
I think she's living either in
California or perhaps in South Africa
which was her last post
Bloomington Illinois all right good
morning I wanted to thank you for c-span
and thank you for taking my call I would
like to take issue with your claim
concerning President Bush's State of the
Union address in September 2002 the
British released a report and the that
was published in The Times online and a
BBC and I'd like to read you two short
quotes from that report the Saddam
Hussein's agents have been secretly
shopping for uranium in the 13 African
countries that possess it as a natural
resource there were signs that the Iraqi
is concentrated on the Democratic
Republic of the Congo when there where
there is a black market in uranium now
mr. Wilson do you investigate those 13
countries
and did you investigate the Democratic
Republic of Congo claim well thank you
very much for your call no in fact the
only country that I investigated was
Nisha and in fact I did not write my
article until it was the State
Department spokesman and if the the
surfacing of the forged documents that
made it clear that the country to which
the president was referring when he when
he cited that British intelligence was
near simple as that question we have
been talking this morning all morning
about Thomas Friedman's column in The
New York Times this morning I'd like
just to get some of your reaction to it
because of your knowledge of it he
basically brought out four different
points that he thought should be looked
at first of all he said that Secretary
of Defense Rumsfeld should be fired
today I said I've said that actually
since September but I've been repeating
it for the last few days as well at some
point there has to be political
accountability for what has gone on it
would be a travesty to not to assume
political responsibility one of the
things that we want to avoid is is
tearing our wonderful soldiers sailors
airmen and Marines for something that
that a few of them did on the other hand
it is important that there be political
responsibility assumed I must say that
if you take a look at any number of
these issues one of the things that is
consistent is that as I've said
repeatedly the president remains far
more loyal to his senior staff than they
do to him or to his policies and on the
diplomatic front he he says that that
the president should convene a meeting
at Camp David should include the UN
officials presidents of Saudi Arabia
Egypt and many others from the region
where should set them all down and say
I'm sorry I think that's probably good I
think there are some other tangible
steps he needs to do I think we need to
make public the International Commission
on the Red Cross reports immediately I
think we should be prepared to invite
the ICRC and the International Red
Crescent to assist in either a
supervisory role or at least a daily
monitoring role as as demonstration of
the rest of the world that that we are
prepared to be fully open about how we
conduct our activities not just in these
prisons in Iraq but also in Afghanistan
and even
one Tana moe I think this case
demonstrates that that that we do need
to make amends with the international
community for these actions in these
photographs as with respect to having a
broader engagement including a summit at
at Camp David or somewhere else I think
that's a that's a good idea
I argued in an article in September that
in the context of reconstruction we
needed to invite the world in and that
included all the neighbors and the rest
of the Arab world as well ambassador
back to your book only showing one final
picture and that is you with Tim Russert
if you've talked over the past 45
minutes a lot about your relationships
with journalists and members of the
media especially since this happened has
what kind of experience has that been
for you to be on the the somewhat
opposite side of the media or the
government no but in actually putting
this picture in your book name my
relationships with senior media actually
go back to the first Gulf War when
everybody came to Baghdad during Desert
Shield and Desert Storm and at that time
we understood that the story was very
important and we understood that it was
important for Americans to understand
what a dastardly deed Saddam Hussein had
done going into Kuwait and in order to
do that we were fully prepared to to
tell the story on a regular basis to the
media as my wife likes to point out
aren't you glad you were nice to the
media then in this period one of the
lessons and I try and put this in the
back of the book as sort of a summing up
statement one of the conclusions of all
of this that we have been through is
that our democracy is still the best
form of governance known to humankind
but in order for it to remain strong we
need to be better stewards and that
includes the press and it also includes
individual citizens and if there is a
lesson from my experience it is that the
public square is open to all citizens to
step into and air their grievances and
to call their government to account
this is the book ambassador Joseph
Wilson's diplomatic memoir the politics
of truth published by Carroll & Graf
thank you very much for joining us today
and taking our of your calls thank you
very much in about a half an hour we're
going to change topics and take a look
at